how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about Marvel and of
course everything relating to the MCU
and today we have amazing news now right
now we're living in a pretty weird time
due to kovat 19 unfortunately a lot of
things have been pushed back in our
world such as the Black Widow release
date and pretty much all other release
dates for all other Marvel projects and
Comic Con themselves even came out and
said that they were going to have to
cancel Comic Con this year however that
has changed sort of this year they're
going to be doing a Comic Con home it's
going to be live broadcasted to where
everybody can see it
so this year is actually going to be a
pretty special Comic Con event because
everybody's going to be able to have
access to the same thing including a
couple of new Marvel Studios trailers
coming out and those trailers are going
to be for the one division series and
the Falcon and the Winter Soldier series
we got some big news today so let's
break it all down but first just want to
say congratulations to youtube user
toxic gaming for winning the Funko pop
Ironman giveaway he's already been
contacted and will get his prize very
soon and for the rest of you I'm going
to be doing another Ironman Funko pop
giveaway because many of you said that
you liked it so much I figured I'd do it
again all you got to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel like the video
and leave a comment about the video down
below so this year we're getting a
digital San Diego comic-con now San
Diego Comic Con is usually where most of
the new info in our world drops last
year we got the entire phase 4 slate
from Marvel released and although we
haven't heard much about Marvel's phase
5 slate being released during San Diego
comic-con this year we have heard of two
major things one the trailer for the Wan
division series will be released and two
the trailer for the Falcon and the
Winter Soldier trailer will be released
and this will be pretty special because
typically it's only the people that are
in Hall age that get to see these
trailers but this year everybody is
going to get to see what they release
now there is a little bit of a catch
that comes with the release of these
trailers and that has to do with the
filming and the production of both of
these shows there have been reports that
the Wan divisions show is pretty much
complete all the filming is done and
most of the editing and visual effects
are done as well and this was reported a
few days ago however the
Falkon in the Winter Soldier series has
not finished shooting yet so most of the
editing and visual effects hasn't even
been gotten to yet which is leading many
people to believe that the Falcon and
the Winter Soldier series although was
supposed to come out before the one a
vision series may come out after and the
first Disney Plus show that we get for
phase four maybe one division in fact
the one division series could be the
first thing that we actually see from
phase four this year
originally it was planned for a release
date of December of 2020 and this was
already moved up from its original
release date but now it's even further
along than the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series which was supposed to be
released in August now considering the
fact that the Falcon and the Winter
Soldier series was heavily delayed due
to the corona virus and is just now
going back to work on filming some
scenes there is a possibility that they
could switch the release date with the
one division release date which would
make one division coming out in August
now this isn't official right now but
considering the fact that Marvel has had
to move a lot of things around due to
the corona virus it seems like a very
logical play by them considering the
fact that what we've heard is it's done
and whan division is going straight to
Disney Plus anyways as originally
planned and everybody is at home right
now streaming from their televisions so
it seems like Marvel and Disney wouldn't
really sit on a complete project that is
going to go straight to streaming so
there is a possibility that we could get
the one division series before we get
any other project of Marvel's phase four
black widow of course now coming out in
November so this year there could be
some pretty big announcements at San
Diego comic-con including the release of
to Disney Plus trailers for one division
and the Falcon and the Winter Soldier
now regular Comic Con before it got
changed to Comic Con at home was slated
to begin on July 23rd so we can assume
that it's going to be somewhat near that
release date for at Comic Con at home
when I get an official date of course
I'll be sure to do a video on it so let
me know how excited you are to get two
new trailers for one division and the
Falcon and the Winter Soldier in the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video and subscribe so you can stay
up to date on everything relating to the
MCU and for live updates you can follow
me on Twitter as well as always thank
you all so much for watching Wolf Wolf